[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
sylvain qu'est ce que tu fais là bas mon
choix je vous attends je lave on m'a dit
vous m'avez posé sur un vous aussi vous
choisissez
vous
ce matin il ya ma mère elle n'arrivait
pas démarrer la bagnole je vois qu'elle
m'appelle j'étais encore dans le cube
grasse mat oblige c'est le week end elle
me dit mon chéri la voiture veut pas
démarrer une petite icône qui clignote
le tableau de bord faut que tu es mort
je lui dis [ __ ] merde je suis claqué
c'est quoi comme icône que je lui dis
mais il me dit c'est un petit bonhomme
qui fait qu accor jeudi un bonhomme qui
fait qu'aucun je me disais elle a craqué
l'ancienne où doit être encore défoncées
de la veille on voit au moins 1 mm est
ce que je lui fais pilar elle m'envoie
la photo de l'icône en question sur vos
portables garder ce qu'elle m'en voyez
j'ai dit moment c'est pas un bouc qui
pose une peche ce qui fait - quote la
bagnole feuilleton qu'elle chauffe bien
faire le meilleur achat de toute ma vie
vous voyez en soirée des fois c'est
relou tout le monde seront versés verts
etc et regardez ça sens vis sur les
bouteilles ça c'est une bouteille de
coca normal hop vous l'a retourné
et
si nabil aulas sait trop bien
il y a des milliers milly milliers
milliers d'années en arrière quand nous
marchions à quatre pattes comme nos
cousins les singes nous étions très très
velu et quand nous rencontrions
quelqu'un on lui disait à peu près
quelque chose comme 1
ce qui voulait dire quel plaisir de vous
rencontrer ou alors ouais je ferais
roubian bien et un jour on a voulu se
tenir debout pas comme les singes qui
eux sont restés à quatre pattes debout
et on en essayant d'être debout la
colonne vertébrale s'est placé
différemment les lobes frontaux ont
commencé à se développer la nuque tout a
changé dans notre structure et les
cordes vocales surtout se sont mis
perpendiculaire à la trachée artère et
le fameux
est devenue ho ho ho ho et le fameux
est devenu aa à aa et les voyelles sont
arrivées ce qui a donné l'humain
non mais
voilà toujours des mots des mots encore
des mots
exactement